Quantum link looks more and more like
it's going to get canceled but there
might be two things that can save it
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
as soon as back in September Scott
Bakula announced that he was 100 not
going to be returning to the new Quantum
Leap series I became a little bit
concerned that this show might not last
the full season
now here in the UK it's not actually
airing yet that's a point we're going to
come back to in a minute but I have been
able to completely 100 legally I'm not
using my VPN in an illegal way
and being able to watch the first couple
of episodes and to be honest it's all
right
oh boy
a lot of people have been shouting woke
it and I won't lie they really hit all
the demographics with the casting but
that doesn't really bother me
particularly it's more about the story
and I do like how they've set up a lot
of questions in the first couple of
episodes including why did Ben jump in
the quantum accelerator in the first
place you [ __ ] there must be a reason
for it and I'm hoping that's going to
build up towards the end but stores in
the last 24 hours have been coming out
from lots of different sources
suggesting that Quantum Leap is almost
doomed to be canceled which is a real
shame after the news earlier in the week
that it was actually getting six more
episodes rounding the series up to a
lovely 18. and hey somebody that's had
to put up a lot of streaming series of
like 10 maybe 12 episodes a series of 18
episodes is pretty cool I'm really
loving that NBC have done that
so NBC at the start of the week we're
confident enough in this series to
request another six episodes but was
there a reason for that that maybe goes
beyond just the numbers at home and
whether the show might get canceled or
not well as I say there are two things
that can save Quantum Leap now if you're
a regular Star Trek you know there's a
few people in the industry I speak to
and one of the people I speak to
actually does this kind of thing for a
living is what he does in the industry
he crunches numbers and he does lots of
graphs and he looks at social media a
great deal and this sort of thing and he
builds up
um demographic details for executives to
look at so this person has had a quick
look at these numbers and the stories
that have been released over the last
couple of days and he's basically said
it's not the full picture the numbers at
home are great
but every new series particularly a
series like this does tend to start
quite well and then the numbers tend to
drop almost every series ever made does
the same so he's not surprised really by
the drop but it has been quite
significant don't forget that if you
enjoy the content you can hit the join
button and become a fully fledged side
tracker that really helps out the
channel you can go to cygasttrack.com
there's loads of like merchandise things
on there and a load of new designs
coming very soon also if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the Bell notifications
so you miss none of our new videos as
well as the Sidetrack sides Channel
so I asked him how a threat is the
Quantum Leap do you think they're going
to get a second series and he's like I'm
50 50. it really depends on how they do
on the international market
so that is the first thing that can save
Quantum Leap
this show hasn't really been sold around
the world yet it's not on Sky TV or
anything else in Britain or France or
you're over at the rest of the world not
just yet but this is the main reason why
NBC have increased the series run to 18
because they want to sell it
internationally and most TV services
around the world including sky here in
the UK still need to make this show fit
their calendars and to do that they need
at least 18 episodes so NBC have bit the
bullet they've agreed to do the 18
episodes so they can more easily sell it
abroad now if the show does sell abroad
and does reasonably well that increases
the chances of a season two
significantly so that is the first thing
that can save Quantum Leap
if the French watch it the second thing
that can save Quantum Leap is copper
cooler so even though in September he
came out and said I don't really want
anything to do with this he has seen the
script they desperately wanted him to
return for a part in the series but he
passed on it
but does that mean it's the end of the
story well we know a lot of TV shows
will try to trick us with this thing and
a lot of Executives and marketing people
I'll try and trick us but I don't think
Scott McCool is necessarily doing that I
generally don't think he wants to be
involved this project at the moment
but Sam Beckett could return in the
Quantum Leap series and I think it would
make sense for him too without Scott
Bakula appearing because at the end of
the day
Sam has jumped into another person's
body from our perspective it would be
that person that we would see I think
that would be a very easy way for them
to bring Sam's character back into the
role without necessarily needing scopper
cooler or at least a first I don't think
you can get away with that for very long
you could do that for a couple of
episodes you could bring him back once
you could tease Scott Bakula coming back
but at some point you need Scott at some
point the Sam Beckett we know either in
a mirror or something we have to see him
now there are lots of ways they could
tease that and again Scott Bakula could
be playing a game here with his
Instagram post saying he's not returning
or maybe he just is saying I didn't want
to return to the start and Donald P
balasario could talk him into maybe a
poon at the end because that is the
second thing that could save Quantum
Leap if they have a big serious end and
a decent Cliffhanger some something that
teases Scott for Cooler's return then
yes I think that could be enough to give
Chief Executives just enough courage to
sign the paper on a contract for a
second series
and let's be honest a lot of sci-fi
shows are kind of weak in the beginning
but improve I'm hoping Quantum Leap can
do the same lots of new TV series and
not very good in the first few episodes
and they find their feet they re-jig the
cast about halfway through and they tend
to improve a great deal I really like
Nathan fillions the rookie series the
time at the moment is one of my favorite
series but if you actually look back at
the first half of that series it wasn't
very good they re-jigged a few of the
ideas and they found their feet by
around episode 10. that's quite common
I'm hoping they give Quantum Leap that
chance to find its feet
the other thing that they could do
though and I'm really hoping they do is
bring back the evil leaper now I thought
that was a really nice little plot they
didn't use enough in the original series
obviously because I came in at the end
but that makes for a really interesting
twist I I kind of hope they use that the
main thing I'm really interested to see
is actually why has Ben jumped into the
quantum accelerator in the first place
because he might be trying to save Sam
but we don't know that there might be
some other completely different reason
why
one of the very early rumors was that
actually this whole series was going to
be about saving Sam and somebody came up
with some very clever ideas about how
somebody could maybe take his place but
we know from the end of the original
Quantum Leap series that Sam never
returns home
but there must be some other reason why
Ben has gone into the accelerator and
I'm really looking forward to find out
what that is
so basically guys there it is in a
nutshell Quantum Leap is 100 at risk of
being canceled it has its critics and I
can completely understand why but I
think this show deserves at least the
first season to see how it gets on and I
don't think we should judge it until
maybe episode 10 of 12. let's Let It
find its feet and then if maybe they can
pull something out of the bag and get
Scott Bakula to return he released even
for a bit then I think this show could
still be saved but what do I personally
think
I don't think we'll be seeing Quantum
Leap series 2.
but guys get in the comments and tell me
exactly what you think what do you think
of the show if you've got it in America
and you've seen the first four episodes
are you enjoying it is it any good do
you think it deserves the second series
or is this going to go down again in one
of those series that this the executives
just don't have the balls to give it a
chance or actually is it a woke mess and
deserves to get canceled I'd love to
hear exactly what you think if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out and as always if you want
to become a fully fledged side tracker
and really support the channel because
you love the content hit the join button
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time